the joe rogan experience
damn what did you see jeff or maybe it's
perfect anything
i'd give jeffy i don't know what jeff
bezos looks like to be honest with you
if i saw him at a party i'd be like
that's the guy i'll introduce you go
[ __ ] jesus christ if you want to be so
good i don't i don't internet's not the
place i'm really okay
[ __ ] you
i'll put you in whatever headlock i know
how to do i'll show you how to
kill me triangle i'll show you how to
kill me
as long as you wear black face me you
choke me out and kill them
come on i want to get the i want i want
it to be
so little racism that that's not even a
term anymore
yeah can we get to there i think we can
i hope so
we can get to the point where there's
just morons [ __ ] and people
you can hang out with yeah i think we
can get there
you know [ __ ] people you can hang
out with
people people who love you i was
thinking about you because
you know you're a comic and the thing is
like
it's there's a lot of things to make fun
of but people are so [ __ ] sensitive
right now and and for
for good reason like that's why i signed
with spotify yeah
i'm like i got plans [ __ ] i'm riding
this wave right into the rocks
come with me what are you doing he's
stretching i think about my back
he's stretching that's that's what
we need in california in 2020. he's like
okay how long is this podcast been going
on
three and a half hours let's play a mere
two hours less than the kevin smith
what's the kevin smith one if you had a
guess
i want to say it's five hours what you
weren't here who was here no he was here
for the second one
but there was a really long one before
jamie
jamie uh i i apologize to gary clark
after our last
podcast because i talked so much listen
don't you ever do that well i love gary
so much i love him
i do i love him so much i love you he
loves you
but i think he was really stoned
everybody was great
you're freaking out i freak out all the
time
but i just want gary to know how much i
love him all right
ride the wave suzanne i'm i'm trying i'm
not a very good surfer what do we
wanna do angela death or what let's do
whatcha you gotta do both
we'll do both let's do this one because
i know death is happening
i met you guys let me get my funky
guitar we're going to do let's do what
you're going to do now first bend and
then listen i love that too
let's do angel of death do whatever you
do because i'm starting to get a little
i'm pretty [ __ ] up
how can you tell it's light out i can
tell
okay who knows it means 526
[Music]
this might be the first podcast we ever
make part one
and part two what do you think
how if if we go straight psychedelics we
should totally do part two i think we
should give a round of applause to young
jamie who is
perhaps the greatest podcast producer in
the known universe
columbus ohio shirt reps ohio in a
strong way
the best the best one-handed googler in
the world has ever known
fastest fingers in the west he's he's
telepathic
i'll start talking about [ __ ] teach me i
mean weird [ __ ] hyenas
you guys are like brains yeah there's
yeah we've been integrated in i think
we've integrated
jamie and i are connected or
neuro-linked
yeah if we're in the ether together
what's what's wrong oh this is the old
it's my dad's
oh sorry dad you guys are swapping
guitars yeah we're kind of [ __ ] up how
many guitars
i brought everything i've said this
before i'm gonna say it again
one of the things i love about music is
i don't even know what the
[ __ ] you're doing i got you know what i
uh i'm good with the arms but like the
the the core and some of the
whiffs i want to tighten up jamie's
going to film this
right after here we're going to go right
over to the gym
i'm not i'm going to show you i'm not
kidding either
see my whoop is not in the right place
for kettlebells
you see why my whoop is on top when i do
kettlebells
that's what i do it's a whoops trap
hey we're gonna do kettlebells i
switched that [ __ ]
it shouldn't be any reason that we're
not in the best shape of our lives right
now other than depression
so an age and how dare you me
oh sure you're in the better the best
shape of all of us combined
no we're all going to be okay yeah we
got things all right stay on top of the
waves
don't give up
if we had a drum set we'd be a band
right now that's what i'm saying
i'm saying you don't play drums right oh
yeah
as soon as they figure out he can learn
everything we got a real problem
i don't want to lose him teach him how
to play drums
what if he gets as good as he is is one
hand googling
no no you know what i was thinking about
that i had this like weird like
i was like one day like 20 years from
now when everyone's like
when like joe's like young jamie
because that's where your voice is going
joey he's young undeniable
jamie is young in spirit jamie jamie
look that
up it's 90 year old rogan i can't wait
to see that it doesn't matter how old
jamie gets he's always been young in
spirit i know
when i met when i met jamie i'm like
this dude's cool he's just a fun kid
he's young jamie he's a good crew i had
a ponytail back there
[Music]
i mean i met young jamie at the ice
house in pasadena
that's pretty awesome yeah we were
talking about audio
engineering um here's this cool
[ __ ]
no this is a great crew you got here
like things are going well there's no
crew it's just jamie i know
that's what i say this is a trick
yeah i like how you took the same room
i'm just like we could have i'm going to
do it again in texas
oh my god there's always air travel
international and
is there yes okay when you get the
spaceship
listen my thoughts about austin are if i
do
move there a hundred percent i'm just
gonna fly people in
i fly anybody in let's that's cool it's
a day it's one day let's because by
[Music]
and we'll just go there play a show do a
podcast hang for a week
you know you got to give people the
choice
to do what they want to do
i don't know if they're right i don't
know if you we have to inform people
and then we have to give them the
ability to make decisions and i don't
know if you're right
i don't know if i'm right i don't know
who's right
i'm scared you're scared can you talk
yeah quick that's what we do think
gloves work
for what i don't trust people who drive
with masks on oh it's weird
you're in your own car it doesn't make
any sense where are you going [ __ ]
you're gonna fold you're gonna
interrogation
you're gonna fall you're gonna fold up
shop you [ __ ] [ __ ]
hey
that's the right choice listen you're
always going to have [ __ ]
we have to everything is real all things
are real
liars poets they're lovers
thieves i think everything is real we
gotta all
accept it together recognize [ __ ]
flush them wake him up in the morning
get up slime give him your love
could you imagine i think that's part of
what you're saying is the man
i'm i'm gonna work out to this every day
just wake him up
it doesn't happen on its own you must
force it
[Applause]
you